do you deserve most or all of the blame
for the failure of the business
or are others at fault too
well the business didn't fail it was
doing well
and so
it's closing
closing is like it was destroyed
who deserves the blame for that i'm
asking from your perspective when you
think about it in in the privacy in your
mind
are you angry
at anthony are you angry yourself
both i think that
um
in the privacy of my own mind and
to everybody listening um it's
it's i feel responsible
i feel responsible in the same way that
if you
kind of did something if you were
driving you did something stupid and
caused an accident in which other people
died
you would feel i think horrifically
responsible
and you'd blame yourself because maybe
you looked away or checked your phone or
something
um
but you didn't intend to kill those
people of course
so for me it's like
i didn't intend to kill
you know sometimes i say like my own
child i don't know if that's offensive
to some people but it's like as if i
killed my own
child it was it was it was a business
but it was special
um
so i don't feel
guilt i feel responsibility
and then
um
you know i'm angry at him even though
that anger is
pointless
you